-Good morning.
Welcome to Radcliffe Day 2016.
This is a day to celebrate
Radcliffe's past, present
and future.
I'm Liz Cohen, I'm Dean
of the Radcliffe Institute
for Advanced Study.
Being here among so many of you
who are celebrating reunions
has reminded me that I mark
a milestone of my own--
my fifth year as Radcliffe dean.
And what a whirlwind these
five years have been.
I've enjoyed watching our
three core programs grow.
Our very competitive fellowship
program, our exciting public
lectures and conferences
through academic ventures,
and our renowned Schlesinger
Library on the history of women
in America.
I've also taken great pleasure
in expanding the Radcliffe
professorship program to
help Harvard schools recruit
new diverse faculty talent,
deepening the institute's
integration of the arts
in its programming,
and creating new
opportunities for students
to partake in advanced study
beyond the standard curriculum.
A high point of this year, as
other years in the recent past,
is honoring an inspiring woman
with the Radcliffe medal.
We lauded Supreme Court Justice
Ruth Bader Ginsburg last year,
and Harvard president Drew
Faust in 2014, just to name two.
Today we are delighted
that our Radcliffe medalist
Janet Yellen, Chair
of the Federal Reserve
Board of the United States.
It is our tradition to begin
Radcliffe Day with a panel
discussion on a topic close to
our honoree's head and heart.
At lunch, we will celebrate
Janet Yellen's achievements,
but now we will pay her
the honor of digging
into the subject she
cares deeply about.
That topic is how to build an
American economy for prosperity
and equality.
How to promote vigorous economic
growth that is broadly shared.
In many ways, this
past century has
brought remarkable advances.
In 1916, average life expectancy
hovered around age 50,
for both men and women
in the United States.
Now, it is well above 70.
Today, most citizens'
working lives
involve shorter hours and
fewer life-threatening
hazards than our
forebears faced.
Roughly 63% of us
own our own homes,
compared to less than
half of Americans in 1916,
even if today's rate is slightly
lower than it was a decade ago.
We all enjoy recreational and
entertainment opportunities
beyond our grandparents'
imaginations.
For many of you sitting
in the audience today,
and the ability to travel
to Cambridge to enjoy
this panel would have
been far out of reach.
And watching it online would
have been unfathomable.
While we mark enormous
societal progress,
Americans' equal access to
a better economic standard
of living is shrinking.
We live in an era notable for
stunning growth in inequality.
Right now, the world's
wealthiest 62 individuals
own more wealth than the bottom
50 percent of the entire world
population.
Just since 2010, the fortunes
of those 62 individuals
have increased by more than
half a trillion dollars.
While the wealth of
the bottom 50% percent
has fallen by a full
trillion dollars,
which constitutes a drop of 38%.
The United States is
by no means insulated
from this global trend.
According to a report by the
Economic Policy Institute,
since the 1970s real
wages for the top 1%
have risen 362%, while
real wages for most workers
have stagnated.
The predictable result has been
increased wealth concentration
at the top.
In 2014, the wealthiest 20% of
Americans owned more than 80%
of all American wealth.
In contrast, the wealth
of the poorest 20%
was negative, meaning
that they owed
more money than the value of all
of their assets put together.
Despite the tendency of a
whopping 87% of Americans
to identify themselves
as middle class,
the Pew Research Center issued
a report at the end of 2015,
with its main finding
stated clearly in the title.
The report was called,
The American Middle Class
is Losing Ground-- No Longer
The Majority and Falling Behind
Financially.
Scholars and commentators
of all political persuasions
have expressed alarm.
Alan Greenspan, former
chair of the Federal Reserve
Board-- appointed by
President Ronald Reagan--
has said publicly that current
levels of inequality are,
and I quote him, "not
the type of thing
which a democratic society, a
capitalist democratic society,
can really accept
without addressing."
Elsewhere on the
political spectrum,
economists and public
policy experts--
like Paul Krugman, Joseph
Stiglitz, and Robert Putnam--
likewise worried that
the growing chasm
between haves and have nots
threatens the very foundation
of American democracy.
At the beginning of this
year, officials from the World
Bank at the International
Monetary Fund,
along with former Secretary
of State Madeleine Albright,
all issued statements
within days of each other.
Identifying inequality
as a chief impediment
to sustained economic growth.
It wasn't always this way.
Even as recently as the three
decades following World War II.
Wearing my other hat as a
20th century US historian,
I wrote a book entitled
A Consumer's Republic,
The Politics of Mass
Consumption in Post-war America.
There I showed that
the post-war order,
that I labeled a
consumer's republic,
was built upon an assumption
that was widely shared
by labor, , business and
government officials.
That broad based
economic prosperity
would benefit individuals and
the nation at the same time,
as mass consumers protected
the jobs and purchasing
power of their fellow citizens.
President Harry Truman
made this point often.
To quote directly from one
of his speeches in 1950,
Truman said, "raising the
standards of our poorest
families will not be at the
expense of anybody else.
We will all benefit
from doing it,
for the incomes of the rest of
us will rise at the same time."
End quote.
Moreover, Truman and
subsequent presidents
believed that an
economically secure,
more equitable citizenry was
capitalism's best defense
against communism in
the raging Cold War.
So how did we get
from then to now?
And what can we do about it?
These are the questions
that our esteemed panel
will consider today.
The panel be moderated
by Cecilia Rouse,
the dean of the Woodrow
Wilson School of Public Policy
at Princeton University,
where she is also
the Lawrence and Shirley
Katzman and Lewis and Anna Ernst
Professor in the
Economics of Education,
and a Professor of Economics
and Public Affairs.
She served on President Bill
Clinton's National Economic
Council, and as a member
of the White House
Council of Economic Advisers
under President Barack Obama.
She earned her A.B.
in Economics in 1986,
and her PhD in Economics in
1992, both here at Harvard.
Dean Rouse will introduce
the other panelists.
Please join me in warmly
welcoming Dean Cecilia Rouse.
-So, good morning.
It's an absolute
pleasure to introduce
this morning's panel, Building
an Economy for Prosperity
and Equality.
It's quite a fitting
topic for a panel convened
in honor of Janet
Yellen's selection
as this year's
Radcliffe medalist.
As you'll hear
throughout the day,
Janet's professional
life has been
devoted to studying critical
issues facing the macroeconomy,
both through her writings
as an academic scholar
and through her public
service, particularly
in the Federal Reserve System.
She's been a key player in
maintaining and promoting
the economic health
of our country,
primarily by
working to find ways
to maximize employment,
stabilize prices, and moderate
long term interest rates
through monetary policy.
However, in recent
years that task
has gotten just a
wee bit trickier.
For decades, economists
promoted overall economic growth
with the belief that a
rising tide lifts all boats.
That is, that the fruits and
gains from economic growth
would be shared by all.
This view is perhaps
not surprising,
since between about
1910 and 1950,
wage inequality actually
narrowed, and then remained
relatively stable
until about 1980.
It is pretty clear, however,
that today all boats
are not rising together.
The past 35 years has seen
tremendous economic growth,
but also an incredible rise in
income and wealth inequality.
From 1973 to 2005, the top
1/5 of real family income
increased by about
1.6% annually,
while the bottom
fifth of families
experienced almost no gains.
In 1978, the top 0.1% of
families held 7% of all wealth,
while they held three times
that much-- 22%-- in 2012.
In fact, today we have
levels of inequality
that have not been seen since
the times of the robber barons
over a century ago, with
rather dire consequences
for our economic, political,
and social fabric.
So the speakers on
today's panel will
help illuminate what
we know and don't
know about economic growth
over the past century,
and how it has
been shared or not.
They will also highlight
some of the causes
for the increased inequality,
and perhaps-- just perhaps--
offer a way to address it.
After giving each
of our panelists
a few minutes to discuss
an important dimension
of this issue, the panel will
have a short conversation
before we open it up
to your questions.
So let me introduce
our illustrious panel.
First up is David
Autor, a professor
and associate department
chair at the MIT Department
of Economics.
David is a faculty research
associate of the National
Bureau of Economic Research,
and a former Editor-in-Chief
of the Journal of
Economic Perspectives.
His current fields
of specialization
include human capital
and earnings inequality,
labor market impact of
technological change
and globalization, disability
insurance, and labor supply,
and temporary help and
other intermediated work
arrangements.
He received his Bachelor's
Degree in Psychology
from Tufts University,
and a PhD In Public Policy
from the Harvard Kennedy
School of Government.
Next to speak will be Louise
Sheiner, a senior fellow
in Economic Studies, and policy
director for the Hutchins
Center on Fiscal and Monetary
Policy at the Brookings
Institution.
Prior to joining Brookings,
Louise served as an economist
with the board of governors
at the Federal Reserve System.
Most recently, as
the senior economist
in the Fiscal Analysis section
for the Research and Statistics
Division.
That said, she's also served
in the Treasury Department,
and on the White House's
Council of Economic Advisers.
Louise's research focuses
on health spending
and other fiscal issues.
She is Harvard squared,
having received her PhD
in Economics from Harvard, as
well as an undergraduate degree
in Biology from Harvard.
Third, we have Claudia Goldin,
the Henry Lee professor
of Economics at Harvard, and
director of the National Bureau
of Economic Research's
Development of the American
Economy program.
Claudia is an economic
historian and a labor economist.
She has received many
honors and awards that
are just far too
numerous to name here,
so you can look up on Google.
Her research has covered
a wide array of topics,
including slavery, the
economic impact of war,
the female labor force,
immigration, New Deal policies,
income inequality,
technological change, education,
and the gender gap in pay.
Most of her research
interprets the present
through the lens of the past,
and explores the origins
of current issues of concern.
Claudia earned her
Bachelor's Degree
from Cornell
University, and a PhD
from the University of Chicago.
Last, but not least, I'm pleased
to introduce Douglas Elmendorf,
the dean of the school
that I shall name here,
Harvard Kennedy
School of Government.
Where he also serves
as the Don K. Price
professor of Public Policy.
Doug served as director of the
Congressional Budget Office
from January 2009
through March 2015.
Prior to joining CBO, he
served in many positions
in Washington, including at
the Brookings Institution,
the Council of
Economic Advisers,
the Treasury Department, and
the Federal Reserve Board.
He has worked on important
issues, such as budget policy,
health care, the macroeconomic
effects of fiscal policy,
social security income security
programs, financial markets,
and macroeconomic analysis.
Doug earned his
Bachelor's Degree
from Princeton University,
and his PhD from Harvard.
So David, I will turn
things over to you.
-Thank you.
It's an honor to be here.
It's an honor to be
honoring Chair Yellen,
and to be participating in the
Radcliffe Institute events.
I want to just frame
this discussion a bit.
First, I want to talk
about why should we even
care about inequality.
I don't think it's self
evident that we should.
Then I want to talk about
some of the challenges that
have made shared prosperity
a harder goal to achieve
in the last 40 years, than
in the three decades that
proceed it.
And then the other
panelists will
fill in a much more
historical detail.
And also, I set the stage for
how we address these issues.
So first, let me
make the case about,
why should we care
about inequality at all?
We should start off by agreeing
that we need some inequality
in a market economy.
If we don't have inequality,
we don't have incentives.
If we want people to go spend
10 years in medical school,
or two years pursuing a
PhD In computer science,
we'd better reward
them when they're done.
And so inequality is
not by itself evil.
In fact, it can be
quite productive.
The question is, can
we have too much of it?
And in the short run, you
could argue no, it just
makes the economy dynamic.
But I think in the long run, the
answers is possible to be yes.
And the reason the
answer might be yes
is because we have overlapping
generations of parents
and children and families.
And dynamism, in the
short run, can give rise
to dynasticism in the long run.
If we have so much concentration
of income and wealth
among a small group of adults,
then the next generation
of kids don't have the same
opportunities to succeed.
In other words,
equality of opportunity
is one of our greatest
shared values in America.
Something we deeply
believe that people
should have a good start, and
the opportunity to succeed,
on the basis of their
talent and hard work.
And if we make the race
too unequal at the outset,
it's harder and
harder to achieve
that equality of opportunity
over the long run.
And that's what concerns me,
when I think about inequality,
that we can reach a point where
the economic rewards of today
and the incentives are so
great, that the prizes are
so large that pretty
soon inequality
becomes the enemy
of opportunity,
rather than the force
that propels it.
So now let me talk
about, what are
the forces that have given
rise to so much inequality?
As was mentioned by Ceci, from
the end of the second World War
through the early
1970s, we had a period
of extremely rapid productivity
growth and shared prosperity.
That period is
anomalous in history.
People like to say that's
the way it should always be,
but they're probably
the only three
decades in all of human history
that were quite like that.
So I'm all in favor for that, if
we can make that happen again.
But that was a remarkable
postwar period.
We'd had huge technological
advances, huge advances
in skills and education.
And, of course, the US had a
leadership role in the world,
where it was the driver of so
much of what else was going on.
Since that time, one of the
first challenges we faced
is actually slowing
productivity growth.
Productivity growth is the thing
that ultimately creates wealth
that we can distribute.
When that growth slows,
there's less to go around.
And even our huge
rise of inequality
wouldn't seem so awful if
all the boats were rising.
But to have some
people getting so rich,
when productivity
growth is so slow,
means the other boats
are stagnant or sinking.
And you can even
see that, if you
look at the period from
1995 to around 2000,
during the internet
productivity surge.
That was actually a period of
shared prosperity in America.
That was a period when
everyone's raise wages were
rising, when employment to
population rates were growing,
crime rates were falling.
Many, many good
things come from that.
From rapid productivity growth,
and also tight labor markets
that pull wages
up at the bottom.
Harder to accomplish, but
something very much desired.
A second issue
that we have faced
is actually slowing attainment
of higher education.
Education has been
one of the keys
to American prosperity
for more than a century.
Professor Goldin will
speak about that.
But since the early 1970s,
and up until recently,
college attainment rates slowed.
For men, actually fell.
And not only did
that mean that there
were fewer people benefiting
from getting a higher
education-- and the earnings
associated with that--
but that slowing supply
of higher education
actually led to rising
wage inequality.
Caused this premium to
education to rise a lot.
So there are actually
three benefits
to sending people to college.
One is it makes them better off.
Two is that it actually
reduces inequality,
because as you increase
the supply of more
educated workers, their wages
actually come down a bit.
Third, it actually
benefits the workers
who don't go to college,
because it makes them scarcer.
Employers have to fight harder
to get high school educated
labor to do those jobs.
So investment in education
is one of the areas
where the US has fallen short.
Maybe not expenditure,
we spend a lot.
But in actually getting
people to succeed
in going through college.
A third important factor is the
forces of technological change
in globalization.
There's been a lot
written about that.
me just catch summarize
it in a sentence or two.
What those two forces
collectively have done
is, on the one hand, amplify
the value of scarce talents.
People who have
great ideas, people
who can run large
corporations, people
who are fantastic
athletes and entertainers.
They become so
much more valuable
in a world market
where their skills can
be delivered electronically,
or through their products
worldwide.
So on the one hand,
it amplifies talent.
On the other hand, it
can also commodify labor.
If you're not someone
who has a scarce talent,
if you make shoes or
you sew clothes, well,
you're suddenly in much
fiercer competition with people
throughout the
rest of the world.
With whom we can
trade and transport,
or even with technologies
that are beginning to erode
or being able to
accomplish that skill set.
So those factors really
do amplify and contribute
to the growth of inequality.
And then I would
say the final factor
is a certain resignation.
A view that, well,
this is the market.
That's what the market says,
we do what the market says.
Or the view that
actually it's good,
all that inequality-- the
more the better-- just creates
incentives.
And I've already made the
argument that, in fact, you
can have too much inequality.
It can actually be the enemy
of meritocracy, not always
the friend.
And the view that we
have no control over it
is simply incorrect.
Because we can look
around us, and look
at many other advanced
economies-- throughout Europe
for example, or
Singapore-- that have
lower levels of inequality.
Not Singapore in this case.
But have lower
levels of inequality,
high social cohesion,
and the same productivity
growth that we have.
In other words, they have
not suffered terribly
for their burden of
shared prosperity.
And we may not either.
So it is within our control.
The economic forces
are fundamental.
We can't ignore them.
Simultaneously, we
actually have a lot
of institutional and social
and public and political
choice about how we
want to organize,
how we want to share the
benefits of our productivity
and our ideas and our
creativity and our hard work.
So there are challenges,
but there's opportunity.
And there's, in no sense,
inevitable-- not something
that is beyond our ability
to address and correct
and improve.
Thanks very much.
-Good morning.
First of all, let me
say what an honor it
is for me to be part of
such an esteemed panel.
And also to celebrate
Janet Yellen,
who I've long admired as an
extremely dedicated, brilliant,
and caring academic
and public servant.
OK, so Cece and David
have talked a lot
about income inequality,
which is something
that we have known for a
long time is a problem,
and has been an area
of great concern.
But it's only in
the last few years
that we've begun to recognize
an additional source of growing
inequality, and that's
inequality in life expectancy.
So it's long been the case
here throughout history,
in the United States
and everywhere,
that people who are
richer live longer.
So that's nothing new.
We've always known that.
But what we used to think
was that as the economy
would grow, then that growth
would help to narrow the gap.
So if you had improved
public sanitation,
and public education,
those things
would help everybody live
longer, but particularly
the poor.
And you expect the
gap to be narrowing.
But what it turns out
is, in the United States
at least, that gap has
actually been widening.
OK so the first study
that looked at this
came from the Social
Security Administration.
And they took their
Social Security records,
and they divided the
population of men in two.
And they looked at life
expectancy and changes
over time.
So they started with people
who were born in 1912.
In people who were born
in 1912, the top half
of the income distribution
lived about less than a
year, almost a year longer
than the bottom half.
So the bottom half of the
income distribution at 65
could to expect to
live almost until 80,
and the top half
until 80 and 1/2.
Now, fast forward
30 years later.
We're talking about the
cohorts who were born in 1940,
and that gap in life expectancy
had widened to over five years.
So now there was an over five
year difference at age 65
and how long the top half of
the income distribution lived,
relative to the bottom.
And that came because the bottom
half of the income distribution
did have increases in life
expectancy, but only about 1
and 1/2 years.
Whereas the top half of
the income distribution had
increases in the life
expectancy of about six years.
Now many other
recent studies-- you
might have heard about a study
from Raj Chetty and coauthors
using incredibly rich tax
data-- have found the same thing
recently, which is that those
in the bottom of the income
distribution had gained very
little in life expectancy.
While those at the top have
experienced major improvements.
A study that came
out from a panel
that I was on at the
National Academy of Sciences
said, well, what happens
if these trends continue?
So if these trends
continue, we take the cohort
born in 1960--
basically my cohort--
and say, let's now compare.
We used quintiles, so let's
compare 20% of the population.
So let's compare the
bottom 20% to the top 20%
of the population, and see
what changes in life expectancy
will be.
And what we found is that
if these trends continue,
we can expect the bottom
20% to live 13 years less,
from age on, than the top 20%.
So an extremely big
difference in how many years
people are living.
So think about it,
not only have we
had income inequality, wage
stagnation at the bottom,
but also changes
in life expectancy.
And when we talk
about life expectancy,
that's because it's
easy to measure.
We know when people die.
But it's not just that
we're all equally healthy
and just sort of die
at different ages.
We know that if life expectancy
is so widely different,
then so is health.
In fact, health economists think
the better measure of your age
is not how many years since
your birth, but before you die.
That's going to tell
you how healthy you are.
So people at the bottom
have had little income,
little improvement in
health, little improvement
in life expectancy.
No wonder there's so
much anger out there.
Very big difference.
You've probably heard
about a recent study
by Ann Case and Angus
Deaton, who won the Nobel
Prize in Economics.
They looked at
something quite similar,
they looked at death
rates from 2000 to 2014,
for people 45 to 55.
And usually, we think
that over time death rates
decline, life expectancy
increases because we're all
getting richer, and we
have better medicine
and better technology.
But what they found was
actually an increase
in death rates for
45 to 55-year-Olds,
particularly those white
males without a high school
education.
And where did those
death rates come from?
They could look at the causes.
Well, they came from things like
increased suicide, alcoholism,
and drug addiction.
So it's a very concrete
example of the despair
that's out there.
Now, how does this relate
to income inequality?
The truth is, we're
not really sure.
Is it the same thing?
Is it just another
manifestation?
So some people
think it's actually
the income inequality that is
creating the life expectancy
inequality.
That could come because people
at the top of the distribution,
they're still at the
top 20%, but they
have so much more money
than they used to,
relative to the bottom.
And maybe they're
able to use that money
to buy things that
increase their lifespan.
It's possible that just living
in such an unequal society
creates a lot of stresses and
strains that affect health.
And it's possible that now
income can now buy things
that it couldn't buy, that
will help increase your life
expectancy.
So it's possible.
The causality could
also be the reverse.
It could be that we've had
health inequality, maybe coming
from different
things in childhood.
And the health inequality
leads to income inequality,
because people who are not
in good health-- particularly
mental health-- are not going
to end up working and making
a lot of money.
So that's a possibility.
And it's also
possible that's all
coming from some other factor.
Something like education,
the quality of education,
or the skills that people are
learning when they're young.
There are skills like
perseverance and self control
and discipline that
can help affect both
your income and your health.
So we don't really know.
One thing that we do know is
part of the changes is smoking.
So we know that the high
income people started smoking
first and quit smoking first.
But researchers say that
could explain maybe 20%-30%
of the widening gap
in life expectancy.
So this is a clearly
huge issue, and we
need to know more about it,
and understand more about it.
But in any case, it
seems like any measures
that we can take
that would likely
reduce income inequality would
probably have a benefit on life
expectancy inequality as well.
Typically things that
are, like, investment
in children, improvements
in education,
because we know that education
and health are actually
quite correlated.
And there's evidence
that actually
calls that more educated
people take measures
that improve their health.
So let me just say,
the gap life expectancy
is something that we
need to deal with.
It affects how we think
about society in general,
and also how we think about
programs like Social Security
and Medicare.
Because we think
of those programs
as progressive programs,
because the people at the lower
end of the income
distribution get a better deal
from Social Security
and Medicare
than the people at the top.
But these programs are programs
that pay out for every year
that you're alive.
So widening disparity
and life expectancy
is also meaning there's widening
disparity in the returns
that people are getting from
programs like Social Security
and Medicare.
And so, when we start
to think about how
to reform those
programs, which we will
be doing over the
next 10 to 15 years,
it's something to keep in mind.
But I think that's
actually second order.
I mean, the way I think about
the increase in life expectancy
is it's a really concrete
example of what's
happening to our society.
We can argue about what's
happening to wages, the bottom,
and whether or not we're
measuring it right.
But we know we're
measuring life expectancy,
and so I think it should serve
as a clarion call to say,
we really need to do
something about that.
Thank you.
-Greetings.
So one of the many
nice things about being
a historian and an
economist is that I can
do really great back casting.
And I get it right
almost every time.
So, I want to tell you a story.
And it's a story about
a bold investment
that the US made in the early
part of the 20th century.
And the investment
was made locally
and at the state level, and
not nationally by and large.
And it reflected a commitment
on the part of most Americans
to provide education
to its youth,
although the south and African
Americans in many regions
are sad exceptions to my story.
So it was this
investment that led
to a great narrowing of
the income distribution,
and it is the slowing down of
these educational investments--
and David remarked
about that-- that
produce much of the widening
of the income distribution.
So I'm going to
have a few caveats
at the end of my remarks
about the top 1%,
but right now let's say
that my remarks are going
to be about the bottom 99%.
that is a pretty big group.
So from the end of World War
II to around the late 1970s,
America grew together.
Economic growth, as
we've heard from others,
was largely shared.
And it was, moreover,
rather strong
in an exceptional period.
The bottom fifth of
families in that period
experienced income growth that
was actually a bit greater
than that of the top
fifth, and the middle group
had growth in-- believe it or
not-- the 2.5% range average
annually.
So everyone was doing
better, and they
were doing better in each
part of the distribution.
But after the late
1970s, America
began to grow out apart, and
growth was fairly anemic.
The top 5% grew, yes, at more
than 2% average annually.
But the lowest fifth
hardly grew at all.
So how did the US
once manage to have
economic growth with equity?
And the answer must
be sought, actually,
in the late 19th
century, when incomes
had become extremely unequal.
America, in even
earlier times, was
known by de Tocqueville and
others as the best poor man's
country.
If you were poor in
Europe, and you came here,
you would do much better.
But it had become a place of
robber barons in the Gilded
Age, and the land of
rising and high inequality.
Discontent was intense, and it
gave rise to many third party
movements--
populists, socialists,
and rampant
anti-immigration sentiment.
Sound familiar?
The returns to a high school
degree in 1900 were very high.
And even an ordinary
clerks and bookkeepers
made substantial incomes.
Part of rising inequality
came from an increased demand
for skills that could
be provided in schools.
That is what we now term
skill-biased technical change.
In community after
community in the US,
it was a groundswell for
publicly funded high schools,
and thus was born what we
historians call the High School
Movement.
In 1910, as this movement
began to take off,
European visitors scoffed
at the American notion
of educating its masses, and
they maintained an elite--
but actually quite
excellent-- education
that admitted only the
brightest at 11 years old.
Americans were far
more egalitarian.
By the eve of World War II,
the median 18-year-old male
in the US was a
high school graduate
poised to go to college.
The US GI Bill in 1944
guaranteed a college education
to returning GIs, but a
similar bill in Britain
could guarantee only
schooling to age 15.
The US had made a bold move,
later copied by most others.
The US did the right thing
in expanding high schools
at that period,
and then college.
Mistakes were made
along the way that we
live with now, regarding
standards and excellence.
But this isn't the
time to discuss those.
The question before us is how we
know when major investments are
worth undertaking, when many
of the returns accrue much,
much later, if at all.
In the early years of
the High School Movement,
the returns to a year of
school were very high.
It was palpable.
It was known, even for
that marginal student.
Employers were searching
for workers with the skills
that high school
educated youths had.
Even without any of
the other benefits that
accrue with more education--
such as benefits regarding
health, for example--
the investment
seemed worth the foregone
income and the direct costs.
The same can be said
of college today.
Well identified
estimates indicate
that even the
marginal student has
significant gains to most types
of post-secondary education.
When I first wrote that, I said,
to post-secondary education,
and then I remembered
my own work
on for-profit higher education.
So I said, most types of
post-secondary education.
So, I will conclude.
But before I do, I need to
go back and say something
about that top 1%.
Growth for the top 1% has been
enormous in the past 35 years,
increasing their total
income from 10% to 21%
in that 35 year period.
But in terms of annual
income, the increased value
of a college education is
about three times larger.
And that is a very complicated
calculation that I cannot say,
because I don't have time,
and you don't want to hear it.
So, in conclusion, can we
have growth with equity again?
The issue of growth
is the hardest part.
Equity may be easier.
Thanks.
-Thank you.
I am delighted to be
here for Radcliffe Day,
and honored to be included
in this celebration of Janet
Yellen.
I will use my few
minutes to draw out
some implications of the
other panelists' remarks
for fiscal policy and
monetary policy, two
areas in which Janet
has, of course, played
very important roles.
Also, as it turns out,
two areas in which I have
had the privilege of
working for Janet.
I was a staff economist at
the Federal Reserve Board
in the mid 1990s, when
she was the governor.
And then I was on the staff
of the President's Council
of Economic Advisers
in the late 1990s,
when Janet was the Chair.
And if I were really
smart, I would've
kept following her
around after that,
because I would have
kept learning a lot more.
But other jobs intruded.
But what I want to do
now is to highlight
three areas of fiscal policy.
And I'll focus on federal
fiscal policy, where
I think fiscal policy can play
an important role in helping
to generate inclusive
economic growth.
And then I'll highlight
one recommendation
for monetary policy.
For fiscal policy,
first and foremost,
we should increase investments
in education and training.
Under the current caps
on annual appropriations,
federal investments all
sorts-- for infrastructure,
for research and development,
and for education
and training-- will soon fall
to their smallest share of GDP
in at least 50 years.
That is not forward-looking,
growth-oriented economic
policy.
And it is particularly
unfortunate for people who are
growing up in poor families,
or in areas with low average
income, because those people
cannot rely on their families,
or their communities, to
provide high quality education
and training.
Federal support, directed
in the right way,
can make a substantial
difference.
Now, the money is not a panacea.
As David noted, we don't spend
all of our education dollars
wisely-- current
location excepted.
But studies show that when
additional money is given
to poor school
districts, for example,
the students in those
districts do better.
So there are a lot of steps
to making our education
and training in this
country more effective.
But a simple starting
point is to increase
federal support for those
issues, not to cut it.
Increasing federal investment
is especially inappropriate now,
because market interest
rates that the Treasury pays
are so low, and will probably
stay low for some time.
And in research that Louise
and I are doing together,
we show that low
interest rates generally
imply-- as one might expect--
that the federal government
should, in fact,
issue more debt,
and undertake more
investment, than it
would under other conditions.
A second way in which
federal fiscal policy
should help to generate
inclusive economic growth
is to maintain benefits for
lower and middle income people,
rather than cutting them as
part of some deficit reduction
effort, or for other purposes.
Federal benefits, transfer
benefits in general,
play two crucial roles.
One role is to help
children growing up
in families of modest
means get a stronger start.
A small but growing
body of evidence
shows that federal
subsidies-- for health
care, for housing,
for education,
and for other things-- helps
children earn higher incomes
later in their lives.
So in many respects,
those federal benefits
are a true investment.
But benefits also
matter because they
protect people, to some extent,
from the vicissitudes of market
forces.
As a number of the
panelists have said,
incomes for people on the
lower and middle parts
of the distribution
have grown very slowly
over the past few decades.
But those are market incomes.
If one then incorporates the
effects of transfers and taxes,
incomes in the lower and middle
parts of the distribution
have done much better.
Not super well, but much
better than they would have.
So that the tax
and transfer system
has limited the extent
of widening in standards
of living, in the face of
this very sharp widening
in pre-tax,
pre-transfer incomes.
Moreover, tax and
transfer system pays
plays a very important role
during economic downturns.
In this last downturn,
market incomes
for people in the
lower and middle parts
of the distribution
fell markedly.
But their incomes after tax
and transfers were incorporated
were much more stable.
So these benefits play
absolutely crucial roles,
both in laying the groundwork
for future, more equal growth
in market incomes, and
for protecting people
from a diversion, so marketing
comes in economic downturns
or even over a period
of several decades.
A third way in which
federal fiscal policy
should be used to help generate
inclusive economic growth
is to keep the total demand
for goods and services
high enough that we
achieve full employment.
Full employment is
tremendously important,
for both economic
and social reasons.
Tight labor markets draw
people into the labor force,
and they push up
the growth of wages.
And those factors are especially
important for lower income
people who are more likely
to lose their jobs when
labor demand is weak, and
who have less resources
to fall back on when
they do lose their jobs.
So full employment
allows for more income
for people who need it.
It also fulfills our
social commitment
to have an economy in which
willing workers can find work.
Unfortunately, maintaining
full employment
is likely to be quite
difficult in the coming years.
In each of the past
three recessions,
the Federal Reserve has
cut the federal funds rate
by more than five
percentage points.
But with market
interest rates so low,
they are very unlikely
to have that much room
to cut when the next
recession arrives.
That means that counter
cyclical fiscal policy--
cuts in taxes or increases
in federal spending
when the economy weakens-- will
be more important in the coming
decades than it was the
1970s and 1980s and 1990s.
We should be strengthening our
automatic fiscal stabilizers,
and developing a
set of policies,
additionally, that we could
put into place if needed.
A rush to reduce budget
deficits after 2010
was the biggest error
in economic policy
in this downturn,
in this country,
and we should not make
that mistake again.
My last and shortest point
is about monetary policy.
To help generate
inclusive economic growth,
the Federal Reserve
should continue
to focus on both
maximum employment
and on stable
prices, the two parts
of its so-called dual mandate.
To be sure, monetary policy
cannot achieve full employment
on its own in most
cases, because of both
the longstanding reason-- that
structural problems can be
important in labor markets--
and for the new reason,
that the Federal Reserve will
have less scope to cut rates
in the future.
But saying that the Reserve
cannot achieve full employment
on its own, or cannot achieve
it just by reducing the federal
funds rate, does not let the
Federal Reserve off the hook
in what it needs to do.
Since the financial crisis,
under the leadership
of Ben Bernanke
and Janet Yellen,
the Federal Reserve has
developed creative ways
to accomplish the
mandates that had
been set for it in law of
maximum employment and price
stability.
We should be very
grateful that they
had the wisdom and
the analytic skill
to develop these new tools.
And we should expect them
to use those tools again
when future conditions warrant.
Thank you very much.
-So, I'm going to ask the
panel a question or two.
But I believe you have
cards in your folders,
and so you can take this
time to write questions.
That's what those cards are for.
And I think there
are individuals here
to whom you can
pass those cards.
And that's how we'll
be doing the Q&A.
So I wanted to make sure
I made that announcement.
OK, so one topic
that's been fairly
hot in the presidential
elections so far, the campaign,
is international trade, and
its responsibility in possibly
increasing community quality.
None of you mentioned
it, I was wondering
if anybody-- oh, maybe you
did, David-- but I was just
wondering if you could
say a little bit more
of what has been
the role of trade.
What should be
the role of trade,
especially as we are becoming
a more globalized economy?
-Sure.
This is something
I've worked on a lot,
and trade has always been a
contentious economic topic.
And the debate around trade
in the political circle
has always been bipolar.
On the one hand, you have
folks on the left saying,
trade is good if we export more
than we import, because we win.
And otherwise it's bad, if we
import more than we export,
we lose.
And then on the other side,
promoters say, trade is good.
Everyone benefits.
It's a win-win.
Neither of those
views is accurate.
Economists have
always understood
that trade promotes economic
growth, whether you have trade
deficits or trade surpluses.
But it's also redistributive.
In general, it
diffuses beneficiaries
by lowering the prices
of goods and services.
And it creates
concentrated losses
among workers in
import-competing sectors.
Historically, we've known that,
but we haven't seen it so much.
In the last 20 years, we've
really seen China's rise
as an extremely
productive, competitive,
international
manufacturing superpower
has been very good
for China, very good
for most of the world.
And good for the
US in many ways.
But it's also been
extremely disruptive
for import-competing sectors--
for manufacturers of shoes,
and textiles, and
leather goods, and toys,
and electronic assembly--
literally resulting
in the reduction of on the
order of about a million US
manufacturing jobs during the
decade starting around 2001.
And we can see that.
You can look at
places where furniture
was made, where shoes were
made, where assembly was done.
And you can see
those jobs-- not only
do you see employment
decline, but you
see broader economic malaise.
You don't see workers
costlessly reallocating
into new activities.
And this has been
economically painful and also
politically consequential.
And, in fact, you can see
that in the areas we're
most impacted by
this trade exposure,
we see growth of
polarized politics.
In the more white,
non-Hispanic Republican areas,
it's led to the rise
of the Tea Party.
In actually left leaning and
minority intensive locations,
it's led to more and more
strong left wing politicians.
I'm sorry, I'm
going on too long.
Let me just conclude.
There actually is
an economic origin
for this debate is bubbling
up in the current presidential
election.
But I actually think it's
healthy in the following sense.
There's now greater
understanding and recognition
on both sides file that
trade has benefits and costs.
It's not a win-win.
We've always known
that, as economists.
Now we can recognize
that as politicians,
and hopefully we can
have trade policy
that both recognizes the
benefits of globalization,
and spreads those benefits, and
compensates the individuals who
bear the brunt of it.
-I just want to add
to David's points.
A very simple point, which is
that he talked about trades
and goods, and
immigration is also-- we
could say the same
things that David
said in talking about
immigration as well.
-So, I didn't fully
hear what we should
do about it, because in
every trade agreement,
there is an attempt to
compensate the losers.
Because everybody
worries, sure, we
know the losers are those
who lose their jobs,
but it can't be that all job
losses related to the trade
agreement.
So we tend to write the
eligibility rules very tightly,
so that a small fraction of
people who might ultimately
have been affected-- So
I'm going to push back
with you a little, David.
And ask you, really, how should
we see this polarization?
It is a challenge for whoever is
going to be in the White House
next.
What really should they
be doing differently?
-Trade is not a bogeyman.
There are lots of economic
forces that are disruptive.
Immigration is one,
technological changes.
If I'm replaced by machine, as
opposed to a foreign worker,
I'm out of a job.
So I actually don't
think we should
try to make trade adjustment
narrowly tailored.
You shouldn't have to prove
in a world without trade you
wouldn't have lost your job,
in a world of technology you
would've.
We should have adjustment.
We should facilitate people
whose skills become obsolete,
or whose industries closed down,
to make investments in skills,
or to help them ensure
their earnings losses,
at least temporarily, as
they move across sectors.
You don't need trade
adjustment for that.
We could actually make
the Earned Income Tax
Credit an Earner's Credit, that
wasn't dependent upon having
young dependent
children to access that,
and get higher earnings in not
particularly high wage jobs.
So I think there's a
broader answer to that,
that's not trade specific.
-OK, fair enough.
-Well, yes, I just
want to add to that.
So I think that that's
one of the things
that we're finding, is that
we've had a policy that
worries more about incentives.
And we don't want to put bad
incentives in, the people won't
work, or whatever.
And so, we don't do things
that would help people.
And I think what
we're realizing,
it does have social
consequences.
It has consequences for
the children, the families.
And that maybe just in terms
of the weights that we're
putting on-- of things
that we typically
think of pro growth as
low taxes and trade--
that there are costs, that maybe
we're starting to recognize
are bigger than we thought.
-I agree with everything
that other people have said.
I'll just add that
I think we tend
to talk in this country
about the importance
of overall economic growth.
And for many people, they
leave the distributional issues
aside.
They're somewhat
uncomfortable to talk about,
they can have a feel of setting
people against each other.
But that logic, that
focus on overall growth,
worked best during a period
when the rising tide really
did lift all boats.
And if the rising tide is
not going to lift all boats--
and it has not lifted all boats
over the past several decades--
then we just need
to be more explicit
about our distributional
concerns, if we have them.
And my view is, those
concerns are crucially
important for sustaining
the social cohesion
that the country depends on.
And that's important for
setting future economic policy,
it's important for the country's
leadership in the world,
it's important for
the way we tackle
social issues in this country.
The sense of people that
they're not together,
but they are apart, is a
very big problem for us,
and not what I think many of us
think of as the American way.
But to change that,
we really have
to do significant
things to help people
who are being left behind,
whether because of trade
or because of technological
change or something else.
-So, many of you have argued
for increased assessments
in infrastructure.
I heard infrastructure,
R&D, education.
And how do we ensure that those
investments are effective?
We all worry about investments
in the bridge to nowhere.
I think there might have
been a New York Times
article about an infrastructure
investment that was
[INAUDIBLE].
So if we're going to be
increasing these investments,
how do we ensure that they're
going to the right people,
places, things?
-Want me to take that?
-Please.
-So, that's obviously
very difficult.
I think we have had a move
towards evidence-based policy,
where people are trying to
actually think quite carefully
about what investments
do make sense,
what investments
don't make sense.
People say, oh, we should
have high speed rail,
but maybe that doesn't
necessarily make sense
for the United States.
And so, you don't want
to just do investments
without thinking
carefully about it.
Now, the political
process gets in the way.
And that's where the bridge
to nowhere problem comes.
Because if you're going
to spend it in one place,
and it makes sense, well,
everybody needs theirs.
And so then you end up
spending in lots of places,
and so that's an issue.
But if you think about Doug's
point about rates of return,
and interest rates
now, we can afford
to make investments that
have less than ideal returns.
They're not going to be perfect.
It's going to have to go
through that political process,
and you're going to
end up having things
that you don't want.
On the other hand,
interest rates
are very low, so we don't need
to have huge rates of return
to make it matter.
And to the extent that
these investments now
have greater social return
than we thought before.
We think these problems
are bigger than we thought,
we realize that social cohesion
is really, really important.
Then, you're willing
to put the money,
because we think it
has higher returns when
it does hit the right places.
And so, some of it may
not hit the right places.
But still, it's the direction
that we want to go in.
And I say, I think we've
had a bias towards thinking
that we always want
to lower taxes,
and taxes clearly
raise economic growth,
but the evidence on that
is pretty murky as well.
And so, I think that if we
think this is a big problem,
we want to try to be smart about
how we make the investments.
But still realize
that we're going
to have to keep
trying stuff until we
get to what works, because
we can't just say, well,
nothing works, so we're just
going to ignore the problem.
-Can I just add that as the
Dean of a School of Government,
and a long time
public servant, I
think we need to find ways
to make public service more
attractive, more appealing
to more of the best
and brightest young people.
I've worked-- as
Louise has, and Ceci
has, and others-- with
some terrifically smart,
talented, dedicated people
in the federal government.
But it worries me when I see
the survey of Harvard College
graduates, and 50-some
percent are going in
to finance related things.
I've nothing against
that, but 3%, I think,
were going into public service,
and that worries me a lot.
-We need more public
service recruiters here.
I think that's part of it.
But let me add to this
important conversation
that at least in
higher education,
it's not so much
increasing the amount,
but doing something to stem the
fact that our public colleges
and universitiess-- community
colleges, in particular--
have lost so much.
So it's not as if we're
adding and building
bridges to nowhere.
Really important bridges
have been taken down.
-So I've already got
a set of questions.
So, I think, why don't we
move to some questions.
So apparently a few
of you have asked,
how does gender
and working women
affect the income distribution?
Claudia, I think that
would be for you.
-A pretty complicated question.
Women are the most
interesting, quote, "minority",
because we are everywhere.
We are not segregated
by housing, for example.
So one way that this affects
the income distribution
is that we've had greater, what
we call positive assortative
mating over time.
Which is a wonderful term
for Harvard graduates,
married Harvard graduates.
That's fun.
So what makes that important,
in terms of the income
distribution, is that it adds
a little bit of a multiplier.
That we've seen increases,
tremendous increases,
to the returns to college.
And if you have even more
positive assortative mating,
it means that it in fact,
even to some degree,
widens these gaps, so
we're thinking about it
in the aggregate.
That's one way of
thinking about it.
On the other hand, if
we think about women
as a separate group, which
I said at the beginning
is sort of impossible to do, we
have a set of important issues
that relate to the ones
that have been raised about,
don't forget the children.
OK?
The children are very important.
And so, having a work
environment which
is highly inflexible
means that women either
forgo their careers to
give to their children,
or their children
are left often alone.
Being let out of school at
2:30, let out of school in June.
We've inherited institutions
from a very distant past.
So I see two issues here.
One concerning aggregate
income inequalities,
and the other one
wrapped up in issues
concerning the family, and
women's special role in that.
-Thank you.
David?
Louise, I want to ping
one to you, because I
think this is important.
How do we approach
disparities in health care
in the setting of
continued rise in costs?
-So, that is
clearly a big issue.
We have, of course, just
passed the Affordable Care Act
a few years ago, which is
going to make major differences
in access to care.
It already is.
And costs are something
that the federal government
has to think carefully about.
It's actually not such
an easy question as well.
I mean, one of the things as
we do get richer as a society,
we tend to value health care
a lot more than we used to.
And so, although it's a huge
budget buster when health care
spending keeps going
up, and it makes
it hard to do the kind of
redistribution that we'd like,
there's a trade off,
which is something
that people really like.
It used to be, actually,
maybe 10 or 15 years ago, you
would go to a health care
conference on House spending.
And they'd say, how
many of you would rather
have 1980s health
care at 1980s prices?
And a lot of people
would raise their hand.
And I think that
that's no longer true.
People will say they
recognize that although it's
too expensive, they really
want today's health care.
And so then the question for
policy is whether or not when
we can keep doing that
or want to do that.
At some point, we're
going to want to spend
our money on something else.
Or whether or not-- we don't
need to necessarily slow
technology, but there's just
tremendous waste in the health
care system.
So the Affordable
Care Act actually
had a lot of very innovative
new payment models, that
hopefully will at least slow
the growth rate of health
over time.
But trying to make
it more efficient.
We don't know exactly
what's going to happen.
Health care spending has
slowed tremendously, actually,
in the past few years.
At least six years now.
And how much of that is
this temporary pause,
versus how much of
that is something
that's still a relic
of the great recession
is still unclear.
But the more we spend on
health care, the more important
it is that we spend our dollars
wisely and don't waste it.
And so, I think that
will be something
that public policy
continues to work at.
-I'm going to combine
two questions.
So for labor comps we think of
these as institutional factors
that affect inequality,
which is, what are
the impact of the minimum
wage and unions on the income
distribution?
Would anybody like
to talk about that?
-Sure, I'll take that on.
Both unions and the
minimum wage have
been two of our most
important labor market
institutions for moderating
inequality and affecting
distribution.
Both of them have
been in decline.
Labor unions, at
this point about 7%
of the private sector
workforce belongs to a union.
And that's down from more than
30% on the eve of World War II.
The minimum wage is also at a
considerably lower real level
than it has been
in quite some time.
It's risen recently, but
if we compare to the level,
for example, it
was in 1977, and we
index that to inflation, it
would be about $20 an hour
right now.
I think that we need to
seek new labor market
institutions, actually,
that can address the roles
and formally been played.
I do not foresee a
growth of private sector
unionization that will
reverse that trend enormously.
But that that's not
intrinsically a bad thing,
because labor unions had
positives and negatives.
They were exclusive.
In some cases, they were not
benefiting minority workers,
not benefiting women.
And you had to belong
to a certain company
in a certain sector.
I would like to
see-- and I think
we're actually moving this
direction-- of a broader
set of institutions that
affect the quality of work.
They affect the quality
of economic security.
Whether that's through
providing health
care, not just
through employment,
but through a public provision.
Having labor standards.
For example, the
change in the overtime
rules that the
Obama administration
has just enacted,
making provision
for maternal and paternal leave
for some degree of ability
to leave work for health
and family reasons.
So I think there's a way we can
make these institutions more
broadly accessible, and share
their benefits more broadly.
On the minimum wage
specifically, I
think most economists
are divided.
Some would say minimum
wage is just fine,
others would say it's
quite destructive of work.
I think all would
agree that it's not
our favorite way of
raising earnings.
It's not the best tool we have.
Better tools include the
Earned Income Tax Credit,
that actually incentivizes work
without it costing employers.
And other things that raise
productivity, or even affect
the quality of jobs.
For example, not
allowing employers
to schedule people for work
two hours before their shift
begins.
The minimum wage,
in moderation it
does not appear to have
particularly adverse
consequences, and clearly
has some benefits as well,
in the range that we've
seen in the last 30 years.
If we start raising to $22
an hour, and did so suddenly,
I think we would see some of
the downside cost as well.
So it's one of the
arrows in our quiver,
but probably not the best arrow.
-Would anybody else
like to comment?
No?
OK.
So I think many of
you have advocated
for addressing both
increasing growth
and inequality with--
let's just put it out
there-- more spending.
So are you at all concerned
about the budget deficit
long term?
If not, why not?
If so, how would you
reduce the deficit
without further widening the
gap and income inequality?
-Maybe I should
start with that one.
-Yes, go ahead, Doug.
-So, I do worry about the
federal budget deficit
and debt in the long term.
I worry about it quite a bit.
Federal budget is on
an unsustainable path,
because spending
will outpace revenues
by increasing amounts over
time, pushing up federal debt
relative to the
size our economy,
and that is not
sustainable indefinitely.
So something must be done.
The question is what
and how quickly?
And my own view about
what we should do
is informed by the
perspective I offered earlier.
I think that, given the
patterns of income growth
in this country over the
past several decades,
that the primary goal of
our economic policy today
should be to raise incomes for
lower and middle income people.
And if you take
that perspective,
and take it seriously, than
that guides you to doing and not
doing certain things
in pursuit of more
sustainable fiscal policy.
So from my perspective,
given that objective,
I would not cut
benefits or raise taxes
on people of modest means.
I would at least
focus the changes
on people who have done better
over the past several decades.
So I would cut benefits
and Social Security,
and I would raise income-related
premiums in Medicare,
but I would focus those changes
on the upper part of the income
distribution.
And to be clear about
upper-- before you applaud--
I don't mean just Bill Gates.
Right?
So there's a tendency in
discussions of this to say,
there's always somebody else.
So I would say the top
third, or maybe even
the top half of the
income distribution.
I would make some changes.
Slightly less applause,
but that's OK.
And on the tax side, I
think there's no doubt
that the federal
government will end up
collecting significantly
more in tax revenue 10,
20 years from now, than is
scheduled under current law.
Because I think, in
fact, when you get down
to specific elements
of federal spending
that are of any consequence
relative to the size
of the federal budget, or
the size of the economy,
most people like
most parts of them.
Even if in the abstract, they're
against high federal spending
and would like less.
So I think revenue
will go up, and I
think the trick there
is to tax things
that we're less worried
about discouraging.
The problem with
higher tax rates
is it can discourage work,
it can discourage saving.
One thing we'd like to
discourage is carbon emissions,
so we should put
a price on carbon
through a carbon tax, or
a cap and trade system.
I never get this, really.
This is interesting.
Usually, the budget guy
gets nothing but boos.
And also, in the individual
and business tax codes,
I would personally sweep
out a significant portion
of the deductions and
credits and so on.
And I would not take all
the extra revenue gained
and plow it back
into rate reductions.
I would keep it to increase
overall federal revenues.
So I think it is
possible to make changes
to put the federal budget
on a sustainable trajectory,
without undermining the goal
of inclusive economic growth.
Last thing I'll say
about timing is,
I think the fact that interest
rates-- the treasury borrowing
rates-- are extraordinarily low
now by historical standards,
and are very widely
expected to stay low
for a considerable period of
time, makes this less urgent.
But it is important
to start the policies
that we would like
to change soon,
because almost undoubtedly,
we would like those policies
to phase in very slowly.
So it's not crucial to make
next year's deficit smaller,
or the following year's
deficit smaller, or the year
after that's deficit smaller.
But it is important to be
having policies will have
real effect 10 years from now.
And many of those
are policies that we
should be legislating and
building in adjustment
paths for now.
-Does anybody else
want to comment?
Doug?
-Three cheers for tax increases.
So I'm going to
combine two questions.
They may be related,
maybe not, but I'm just
going to put them together.
So one is that it seems
technological gains will
decrease the need for workers.
If that results in fewer jobs
than potential employees,
how can we, as a society, deal
with large numbers of people
who do not need to be employed?
And how would we put
that into a new economy,
thinking about the gig economy
and other forms of employment
relationships?
David.
-Let me start with
the gig economy.
The gig economy, I think,
actually exemplifies, at least
in my thinking, the
point I was making
earlier about commodification
versus amplification.
And you see both going on.
So let's say you're the software
equivalent of a movie star,
then the gig economy is
a great thing for you,
because rather than
being insulated inside
of one firm, where you
get a pretty good salary,
you can sell you your
services to market.
To the highest bidder.
And the gig economy makes
that easy, easy for people
to discover your talent,
to contract with you.
And so, it amplifies.
Your talents are now going
to be more richly rewarded.
At the same time, if
you're a vehicle driver,
or you're a plumber, or you're
a person who goes to the grocery
store to buy groceries
for other people,
you are now a commodity
laborer on tap.
And so, for some
individuals, that
could actually be
less attractive,
although not an option.
So, for example, I was
recently at a conference,
and I heard people in
the trades complaining
that rather than them having
their own differentiated firms,
they were now basically a
service provided by Amazon.
You tell Amazon what you
want, Amazon calls them up,
sends them out.
You never deal with them again.
They weren't happy
about that model.
So that's the
commodification side.
And I think we need to recognize
that there are both costs
and benefits.
On the one side,
there's flexibility.
And if you're a worker,
you're an Uber driver,
you could turn on your
Uber app when you want to,
and turn it off when you
don't want to use it.
And that's great.
On the other hand,
people also have
a need for economic security.
And flexibility, when I
get to choose, is great.
Flexibility meaning I work
when the market wants me to,
and I don't work if the
market doesn't want me to,
that's not the kind of
flexibility I'm looking for.
So I think this ties
into this point about,
what are the labor
market institutions that
create economic security, even
when there's rapid change?
And they are things
having to do with health
care, good education,
and things that
provide a basic wraparound
set of social services
that allow people to prosper
even in challenging times.
Talking more broadly--
and briefly-- about
where will the jobs come
from, we don't know.
But we have been worried
about the effect of automation
on employment for more
than two centuries.
This did not start with Amazon.
And any general, we've been
impressed by our ability
to think of new things to do.
So in the beginning
of the 20th century,
about 38 percent of US workers
were employed on farms.
If an economist from
the 21st century
had showed up on the farm and
said, hey, guess what you guys?
In 100 years, there will
only be 2% of you working
in agriculture .
So what do you think
the other 36% will do?
They probably wouldn't
have said, oh, software,
personal services, apps.
It's all going to be apps.
And yet, we underestimate our
own creativity and ingenuity,
and also our ability
to consume new stuff.
People, as we get wealthier, our
demand for consumption rises.
If people in 2016 want to
have the standard of living
of people in 1916,
they could do so
by working about 17
hours a week on average.
But most people don't choose to.
They would rather
continue to work hard,
and then play hard, so to speak.
So technological change
will be disruptive,
but remember it's
disruption that comes
from productivity improvements.
That's a good problem to have.
Most economic problems
are problems of scarcity,
not problems of abundance.
So if we really are
getting that much more
productive through
technological change,
it will create challenges, but
also gives us additional wealth
to deal with those challenges.
-Let me add that we have,
in the period that David
was talking about,
worked far fewer hours
per day and per week.
So we've taken our gains
on several margins,
several dimensions.
So we have more goods, more
services, longer lifetimes,
better quality years,
and we also work.
We do work fewer hours per week
then 100 years ago or whatever.
I'm reminded as well that
there's a large literature.
There was a play called
R.U,R. in the 1920s,
so we have lived in fear that
the robots are going to take us
over, that the androids are
going to be doing everything,
that you won't know when you
get married whether you married
to an Android or not.
But this hasn't happened--
-That I know of.
-As David has said,
these have been
concerns for a very long time.
-There have been lots of
questions about immigration,
and how to think about
the impact of immigration
on both economic growth
and on income inequality.
And how should we think
about that relative to full
employment?
If
-David?
-Anybody?
Anybody?
What you said before
about to trade,
but just put in immigration.
It's the same.
-Immigration is an area where
actually the theory is not
that dissimilar from trade.
We understand it should have
distributional consequences.
It creates growth, and
it expands the size
of the economy in general.
It should be a good thing.
It reduces scarcity.
The evidence is actually
much less conclusive
than you would expect.
There is realy-- despite
strong popular sentiment,
and really even firsthand
observation-- economists
have not found strong evidence
that even rapid expansions
of low education
immigration has greatly
depressed wages or employment
of low educated Americans.
And that's very surprising,
because it would
be plausible for that to occur.
The standard
rationalization of that
is they complement each
other, they don't just
substitute each other.
Typically, immigrants do
slightly different jobs
from natives, and
you actually see
natives moving across the
occupational distribution
as that occurs.
But you can understand
why it's contentious,
because you are introducing
competing groups, especially
in the low skill
labor market, where
labor is much more commodified.
I'm in the high skill labor
market, I think many of us
would feel very strongly
that we should be increasing
high skilled immigration.
That one of the US's
greatest strengths
is that we attract talented
people from all over the world.
They come here to be at
places just like this,
and they tend to stick around.
And they produce great ideas,
they enrich our culture,
and they have been central
to our growth and prosperity.
And really the fountainhead
of so much of greatness
has occurred here.
I was hoping I'd
get one of those.
You can make the
counter, even, well,
don't they compete with
high skilled workers America
as well?
Yes, but high skilled workers
in America are doing great.
So we can stand the
competition, I think.
So thank you.
-Let me just say one
other point, which
is that in an economy
with an aging population.
And fertility levels that
are not that-- our fertility
levels are pretty high
by world standards,
for our income
level, but they're
not that high-- in such
a population, immigration
is a godsend.
We're getting all
these individuals,
they've already gone through
those difficult early years.
It's sort of like
if you gave birth
to a well educated 24-year-old
who could take care of you
when you're older, and
was healthy and likable.
So, in fact, the country that
is in the worst shape because
of all these issues is Japan.
So, Japan is doing now
a lot of things wrong.
Well, they have
very low fertility,
they don't have immigration,
their economy is tanking.
And, well, they have people
who are living forever.
Maybe that's good.
But for an economy
like that, immigration
would actually be real godsend.
-So I'm cognizant of the time,
and I do have one last question
that I would like each of
the panelists to respond to.
So, if there were a third
party-- the Prosperity
and Equality Party--
what would or should
its political platform be?
-I'll go last.
Just, everyone choose one plank.
-Well, so the plank
that I would pick
would be government
investment in things, and more
importantly, in people.
-You have to be more specific.
I'm sorry, you're
going to have to be
more specific for our
political platform here.
-You want me to pick something--
you want a skinnier plank.
Too broad a plank.
I think that we should increase
our investment in young people,
particularly lower and
middle income young people,
by using resources from people
who are higher in the income
distribution, and
have done especially
well in the past few decades.
-OK.
Claudia?
-I agree entirely, but as a
historian, I can look back
and I can see enormous
disruption with any third party
movements.
So I don't want a third
party, I certainly
don't want the ones
that have been emerging.
I would like our
current parties to think
better, are to be that
party of Doug Elmendorf.
Both of them.
One could be a little
more to the right of Doug,
and one a little more
to the left of Doug.
That would be a great world.
-The Doug Elmendorf party.
-Well, I've worked
with Doug, so I am
going to sign onto his party.
That's exactly what
I would say, too.
I think, to me, that would
be the most important thing
that we could do.
Just investments
in kids who will
want to make the
country great again.
I think that's how we do it.
-Yes.
I agree.
-There's so much to choose from.
I'm going to take two.
The first one is, I
would like a party that
embraced, as Doug said
earlier, an esteemed service,
both in leadership in education.
I think we live in an era where
after 35 years of denigrating
public service, we have
managed to actually
make it somewhat more like the
people who initially denigrated
it believed.
You go into a post
office, and it doesn't
work, why doesn't it work?
Well, because Congress
doesn't fund it as punishment
for not working well.
You know?
Why doesn't the IRS
answer your phone calls?
Well, we've defunded it.
So of course you hate the IRS.
So I think there's a
self-fulfilling prophecy
around the quality of governance
that needs to be reversed.
The other thing I
would add to that,
that would actually, I
think, complement this,
would be tax simplification.
And this is also
going to Doug's point.
We have so many tax
expenditures that
are basically hidden handouts,
and we could cap them.
There's actually a very
simple way to address them.
Just limiting the tax
expenditure per individual.
You could take whatever like.
You can do it for
charity, you could
do if a mortgage interest,
you can do it for education.
But it's only 0.5% percent of
your adjusted gross income.
That would be a
mind-blowing change.
-Agree.
All right, except.
for Claudia's comment
about the wisdom of
having a third party,
that was very nice.
Thank you.
-Thank you very much Dean
Rouse, and to our panelists.